parte b sea igual a 4
entonces fx es igual a 1 entre x
cuadrada menos 4x determina si f tiene
un mínimo relativo un máximo relativo o
en ninguno de ellos en x igualados
justifica tu respuesta bueno pues aquí
tenemos a fx pero también acá arriba nos
daban cuánto valía f prima de x esto de
aquí recuerdas déjame notarlo
efe prima de x f prima de x es lo mismo
que bueno acá pero acá en este caso vale
4 entonces me va a quedar 4 - 2x esto
dividido a su vez entre x cuadrada x
cuadrada menos acá por x pero recuerda
en este caso acá vale 44 x x todo esto a
su vez elevado al cuadrado muy bien y ya
que tenemos toda esta información
de nuevo mi pantalla y ahora sí vamos a
resolver este inciso b ya sabemos cuánto
vale
fx y cuánto vale f prima de x y si
estamos buscando mínimos o máximos
relativos entonces debemos estar
interesados en los puntos críticos
especialmente cuando f prima de x es
igual a 0 entonces si f prima de x es
igual a 0
lo que queremos es que esté el numerador
sea igual a 0
4 - 2x sea igual a 0 ahora si sumamos 2x
de ambos lados me va a quedar que 4 es
igual a 2 x aunque x toma el valor de 2
y observan era justo lo que nos decían
que x toma el valor de 2 entonces
estamos comprobando en este momento que
f prima de 2 es igual a 0
o dicho otra manera que 2 es un punto
crítico
ya sabemos que si es un punto crítico
pero ahora hay que ver qué pasa con la
primera derivada de la función antes de
dos y después de dos para ver si es un
mínimo relativo o un máximo relativo es
decir si la función está creciendo o
decreciendo antes y después de ejes
igualados y bueno entonces vamos a ver
qué pasa con f prima de x antes de 2
vamos a fijarnos si la función está
creciendo o decreciendo entonces vamos a
escribirlo cuando cuando
x toma un valor menor que 2 qué va a
pasar con f prima de x entonces
prima de x cómo se comporta bueno pues
observa aquí tengo 4 - y no sea
supongamos a x igual a 14 menos 2 es
algo positivo entre algo que siempre
será no negativo porque aquí tengo esto
elevado al cuadrado
entonces me va a dar algo que es no
negativo eso quiere decir que f prima de
x va a ser mayor que 0 cuando x es menor
que 2 no se podemos poner aquí por
ejemplo por ejemplo qué pasaba con x
igual a 1 bueno efe prima de 1 me va a
quedar y me queda 4 - 2 es 2 entre 1 al
cuadrado menos 4 por 1 es 4 entonces me
queda uno menos 4 lo cual es menos 3 al
cuadrado
me da 9
dos novenos ahora esto pasa cuando x es
menor que 2 que pasan cuando x es mayor
que 2 x es mayor que 2 bueno qué va a
pasar con la primera derivada f prima de
x va a ser mayor que 0 o menor que cero
ahora observa voy a tener 4 menos 2 por
algo muy grande lo cual nos va a dar 4
menos algo más grande que 4 y entonces
esto de aquí será negativo y eso quiere
decir que f prima de x va a ser negativo
porque al final recuerda que estoy
dividiendo entre algo que no es negativo
entonces f prima de x va a ser menor que
cero ahora bien que nos está diciendo
esta información que si tenemos algo que
va creciendo va creciendo mientras nos
acercamos a algo donde su pendiente es
cero y después empezamos a decrecer
entonces lo que estamos viendo sin
dudarlo es un máximo relativo
déjame notarlo esto significa esto
significa que x igual a 2 es
máximo relativo del lujo ahora otra
forma de resolver esto mismo sería
fijarnos en qué es lo que pasa con la
segunda derivada de x con f prima de x y
ver si tenemos algo positivo o negativo
y eso nos dirá todo acerca de la
concavidad es decir sacando la segunda
derivada veremos si tenemos algo cóncavo
hacia arriba o algo cóncavo hacia abajo
pero si observas esta función e intentas
calcular la segunda derivada bueno pues
se observa que se ve un poco peliaguda
así que te doy un consejo siempre que
estés en una parte del examen ap y
llegues a una parte que se vea muy muy
peliaguda como tomar la segunda derivada
de f de esto que tenemos aquí se ve
bastante difícil y bastante tardado
busca por otro camino porque seguramente
te saldrá y vas a poder obtener la
derivada de esta función y seguramente
eso funcionarán para obtener el
resultado
no creo que sea el camino óptimo
entonces en este caso una forma sencilla
de resolverlo es pensar qué valor tomar
efe de x cuando nos acercamos a 2 o tal
vez otra forma de pensarlo es qué pasa
con una función está creciendo o
decreciendo a medida de que pasamos por
este punto por el punto x igualados
entonces x igual a 2 es un máximo
relativo esa es la respuesta de mi
inciso b